[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday April 13th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
virtual reality can transport you to A
Whole New World relaxing on a beach or
flying through space without leaving
your home but it can also help bring
people back to places they have been
before places of trauma that they may
need to deal with and this is a growing
area for therapy with me to discuss how
VR technology is helping therapists and
patients is our health reporter Brianna
Abbott hi Brianna thanks for joining me
hey thanks for having me so VR therapy
and the realm of mental health treatment
where does this fit what are therapists
trying to address with this kind of
treatment so therapists and mental
health providers generally are doing a
lot when it comes to trying to find ways
to use VR to help patients and one of
the ways that they're doing that is
doing something called virtual reality
exposure therapy which is sort of a
virtual version of the long-standing
technique called exposure therapy where
people confront sort of memory memories
or fears you know a traumatic event that
happened and they go over that sort of
with a therapist to sort of overcome the
feeling of constantly being under threat
and sort of trying to retrain their
brain to realize that they're not in
that danger again so is this kind of
treatment this sort of work for anybody
who has trauma or is it for a specific
group of people so this can be done for
anyone who has trauma or fears like they
use it a lot for people with fear of
heights something like that if the fear
is Extreme and and interrupts your daily
life or any sort of trauma and so what's
happening with VR exposure therapy is a
lot of the work historically has been
done with veterans with military-like
scenarios and now researchers are really
trying to expand it Beyond veterans to
help folks in the civilian setting that
might have PTSD for other reasons can
can you describe how this works I mean
I'm sure a lot of listeners will have
seen maybe even used a VR headset but
what's it like when you use it for
therapy so what it's like for therapy
right now at least is that most people
have to go into a clinic with a
clinician there say you're using the
military sort of Base scenario that's
called Brave mind they have 14 different
scenarios that you can start in and then
the clinician can actually sort of
change certain things about it like you
can change what kind of car you're
sitting in or you know how many people
are with you and they even have little
canisters that can waft smells over each
of you so you can smell diesel fuel or
things like that and then the clinician
will sort of walk you through that
memory as much as possible because an
issue with PTSD is avoidance but really
helping people's symptoms is Reckoning
with the thing that happened and so they
use sort of this VR therapy to sort of
really slowly immerse the person in a
similar setting and sort of go over some
of those details you mentioned that
historically this has been used for
veterans but that it's expanding out to
other people to deal with their trauma
how are they creating the scenarios for
this specifically when it might be a
very personal or unique circumstance
that somebody went through so they're
doing a few different things in that
there are some researchers that are
going out and taking photos of bars or
certain locations and then recreating
that in a 3D environment in virtual
reality to sort of give them more
options and then there's also quite a
bit of coding involved as well so you
know they'll take some photos they'll
give to some programmers sometimes they
will take objects or things off of the
internet some folks are working on
pulling archival historical footage from
recent historical events that you can
cheaply and more easily sort of design a
lot of these scenarios that get closer
to individuals can you give us an
example of one of the clinicians who's
using the ER Dr Deborah Bedell who is at
the University of Central Florida at the
restores clinic which is a research
clinic for post-traumatic stress
disorder and they were using the VR
Brave mind system but patients actually
started coming to them and requesting
scenarios that they didn't have like
something like a swimming pool or the
Pulse Nightclub shooting because they
were in Florida and so they got requests
for all these scenarios that they
weren't able to fulfill and so what
they've done is you know they started
taking objects or people or cars from
the internet and took photos of things
like surf sides so programmers could
replicate the simulations and now
they're sort of working on a new
platform or a service that could help
create VR scenarios for other clinicians
VR headsets are something that a lot of
people have just at home I mean is this
something they can do by themselves it
depends on what you are trying to do so
if you are are trying to do something
like say you have a fear of public
speaking you could potentially download
software that's just a crowd of people
that you can sort of get up there and
put your headset on and practice
speaking in front of so when you're
talking about someone doing this
independently it really depends on the
specific use case what did some of the
experts tell you are the maybe drawbacks
or limitations to this kind of
technology so there are some limitations
including that a lot of the research
shows that this works about as well as
other therapies like traditional
exposure therapy and a lot of the
research shows that it works best in
conjunction with classic treatment as
well so it's definitely not the end-all
be-all it is like a valuable tool that
clinicians can use but won't necessarily
solve a lot of these big problems when
it comes to the technology it's really
good at animating different locations
but when it comes to like people moving
the Graphics look worse and so it's not
a hundred percent yet on just the VR
side and we're not also at the point
where we can do a lot of these entirely
at home like some of these can be done
directly with a home headset but some of
them like for the brave mind scenario
still require someone to come into a
clinician's office because the
adjustment of the scenarios takes more
computing power right now that requires
a person to go in one concern people
often have with technology and
particularly technology related to
health care is about their data and and
where it's stored how it's used if
you're creating these very personal VR
scenarios should people be at all
concerned about how this information is
being stored or potentially shared with
a company data privacy is always a
concern with the VA they recently
launched an at-home trial for chronic
pain and they actually actually send
headsets home with people and part of
that is because the veterans might not
have headsets at home but also there are
data issues there so you sort of want to
keep it on your own system and so
there's not a clear answer for that yet
but that's definitely something that is
a concern that's going to have to be
worked out okay that's wsj Health
reporter Brianna Abbott thanks for
joining us yeah thanks for having me and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
for more Tech stories head over to our
website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]